they had no idea all the surprises we
have in store come on come on
[Applause]
I know Kevin love's the Philadelphia
Eagles football team for us I know this
because my nanny is obsessed with the
Philadelphia football team yes told me
we all saw him on the field after they
won the Super Bowl yes we have some
photos well there's one player
celebrating with the trophy and didn't
have their up and then here's where you
are yeah yeah he would not let you up
yeah yeah well I have a surprise I
remembered a know what I have a surprise
the Eagles wanted to make it up to you
what do they do
well it's through those doors right up
there Kim
[Applause]
[Applause]
exactly run a good friend of mine can't
talk because you know he's an eagle yeah
I mean he came all the way from Philly
choosing Kevin Superbowl cufflinks and
[Applause]
kudos salutes friends also sent along a
message for Kevin take a look let me see
hey Kevin it's Brandon ground with the
Philadelphia Eagles just want to let you
know that we're over here thinking about
you and we hope that you're feeling
better after we heard you was going on
Kelly's show we knew we had to do
something
so I send my man swooped over to
surprise you we know how big of an
Eagles fan you are yes sir we sent you a
full uniform that you can wear on game
days by the way I hope it fits
let me got your measurements from Dwayne
Johnson hey I hope you're feeling better
and see you soon
hi Kelly no birds
[Applause]
but hey and they signed it know this the
sad part is that this is my size I know
you guys think it's a joke but this is
really my size I'm this is this is a
great thing
hey I appreciate this man I know it was
tough for you to get down here you know
what your buddy flies he gave me
something I went to school and I wore my
hair in the afro like this
and a lot of people had a lot of mean
things to say about it
so that made me feel some type of way I
told my mom and she said promise don't
forget who you are and who's you are I
said okay so today I'm gonna go to
school and I'm gonna come back bigger
and better and don't allow anyone steal
your joy don't forgive them that much
power that your video though has
inspired so many people including my
guest
my first guest y'all she is a Golden
Globe award-winning actress and the star
of blackish the last time I saw her she
was singing a moment like this at the
American Music Awards was awesome say
hello to Tracy on this frosting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and that was your big breakout track
your beer right that's when I remember
most like from you starting and so have
you met her like Drew Barrymore have you
saying have you heard anything not
lately
no lately but what did you hear did she
like it there's no like time limit like
she can hit me up in ten years and
actually that did happen to me with
Steve Carell I didn't meet him for like
a decoration so yeah it was amazing but
this song is blowing up and I saw a
review of it actually on TV recently and
I thought that you might want to check
this out I thought it was pretty cool hi
Kelly and price it's drew here I just
wanted to send you a quick message
saying hi and Bryce I'm such a big fan
of yours and I am so lucky to be the
name of one of your songs and I love
that song so much and Kelly
congratulations on your new show I am
rooting you on and I just think the
world of you I'm such a big fan of both
of you and it's perfect that two cool
people are together right now and I'm
just sending a whole bunch of love
[Applause]
all about you know oh my god I'm like
shaking right now I can finally check
that off the bucket
[Music]
check out these looks right here so
these outfits were designed by that
young girl modeling them all right so at
12 years old she can already say she's a
fashion designer with her own brand and
a growing list of exclusive clients from
self-life skies say hello to Skylar
Johnson I do have a surprise for Skylar
we have someone here who has blown the
fashion and beauty world away she's a
model the woman behind baby fat and so
many other successful businesses Kimora
Lee Simmons come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of crazy like how I mean out of
your kids probably grew up or in a bit
you didn't crawl up in this industry
look at her she's like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so like real tears oh love you I'm
telling you nobody here tonight
can I tell you my favorite part cuz I
was reading a pre-interview and like all
the things like I've seen you in Book of
Mormon I've seen it been frozen or heard
you in froze all the things that you
don't tell him what you know when you
mentioned new girl that's her pool thank
you you're too young so why bearclaw why
was that your boy I love new girls I
actually just did an interview with
Zooey Deschanel I love it like a
die-hard new girl fan but they told me
on the phone they were like okay it's so
like someone's gonna be sitting with you
on the couch and I'm like oh okay
and so they were like oh I was like who
is it and they were like Josh GAD I was
like who's that
so I didn't know who that was so I'm
like a huge fan but I know you as bear
claw so there are so many emotions that
I'm going through right
[Music]
we all have something in common we're
all obsessed with space right like are
you was this before doing the card were
you always into like space kind of stuff
or no yeah yeah yeah I mean I I am I am
into science kind of stuff me too and I
and I really I really love nerds yeah
and I think we forget like how I have
know the rest icing on here a couple
times well okay I love him and we forget
how much science is in your everyday
life that you don't think about you know
even your GPS even like everything we
know you know normally use everyday but
I think it's a it's incredible and we we
actually have some friends at NASA
because we've interviewed I was telling
Tim we we've interviewed them and they
knew that we were all obsessed with
space and I knew y'all are coming so
they sent us something so take a look hi
Allison Kelly and I'm NASA astronaut
Jessica Watkins and I heard Allison that
you have a few questions for us here at
NASA we're working on the answers but in
the meantime we're accepting
applications for a new astronaut class
at usajobs.gov and we're hoping to get
many people to apply but if the three of
you would like to come out and train
with us any time just let us know
thank you Tim to infinity and beyond
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god I'll do it for them and I was
like she just freaked out and then while
my next guest has been celebrating
holidays her whole life without one
family member a sister she never even
knew existed she's hoping that changes
this year
please welcome grace and her husband
Mike we met online so I sent him some
pictures yes my family
oh I was like whoa so of your family all
were just trading info about family
talking and I said I don't know who
those people are but they're not your
family you're adopted yeah it just
trying to be funny trying to be funny
but I was like I was serious at the same
time because I didn't see the
resemblance that you would see in a
normal family yeah at least like one
person looks like right right right yeah
so how did you find out you were adopted
well my aunt actually called me up and
she said just to let you know I want you
to come over to Fort Lauderdale when I
have something to tell you I'm very
important so we both went over there and
she handed me an envelope and said just
to let you know your mom didn't want me
to tell you your cousins didn't want me
to tell you what you were adopted oh wow
okay so what was it I heard it was a
health issue they kind of got you
looking for your family right yeah right
yeah about eight ten months ago you know
she started you know we were always you
know active going to the gym and this
and that she was doing get it girl
and then all of a sudden she told me one
night she said I had to stop I couldn't
finish and I said what do you mean he
couldn't finish she said I just couldn't
do it anywhere I lost my breath and then
over a period of time we got
progressively worse and worse and worse
and we had a couple of like episodes
that's just callin that we wound up at
the ER and then of course they sent us
home after three times yeah I spring you
into action of looking for your real
family just to know the background help
exactly yeah more or less and you know
if she finally got to a cardiologist it
sounding like okay fun is fun but
tonight I'm gonna find your family she
said well how you gonna do that I said
don't worry you know my dad was a
policeman I'll figure it out oh my
Columbo was like you know so then what
happened what happened next well you
know I got home that night and I you
know asked her around the phone I said
where's that envelope and she told me
where to look for it in the house if
your aunt had given you the envelope
right yeah that picture of my mom and
dad and my sister yeah then you know
people would question right you know but
I don't have proof it's crazy your aunt
kept that picture for so many years
actually so anyway so on the envelope
you know it had like the dad's name
where he was from and this and that's
what I had a little bit of information
so yeah so tell us what happened next
Mike well I went home and got on the
internet because I found that envelope
and it had some names in areas so I just
started to doing search through you know
the computer trying to find and paid an
extra little bit of money
yeah and I got cell phone numbers and
landline numbers and stuff like that so
I just started figuring hey I'm gonna
send text out it's kind of fun yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then by sending those
texts in that I was like the next night
on the way back from a ball game I got a
phone call we found out that it was
Grace's sisters that we were actually
connected to right yeah yeah so what was
it like talking to and her name was
Robin right right so I'm supposed to her
and it was it was like talking in the
mirror talking to yourself because she
had the same voice she had the same
demeanor so I just listened to her story
how she was brought up and all this
and I said you know I said you know I
felt bad because I wasn't there for her
all these years so I was the oldest yeah
I was the oldest so then she sent us a
picture of herself and of course he saw
it first and he got emotional and
started crying and I'm like why why you
know and then when I saw it I was like
oh my god she's the spitting image here
y'all gonna meet with Robin for
Thanksgiving Christmas in December first
we kiss we December we're gonna fly up
to Philadelphia and meet up with ya
well I have something to share grace
doesn't have to wait to meet Robin
because she's backstage so are you ready
to meet her right now no I am so excited
for this moment
okay please welcome Grace's sister Robin
[Applause]
well the High School Musical at my
school was the most important thing it
was the one time that everybody gathered
like when we did Wizard of Oz all the
football players were on their knees as
munchkins so one time we're like the
math nerds and the Mean Girls and that
everybody whoops all right hi we're a
date and I got a dog I used to love the
box color yeah just a little Olga V home
perm so that's why you love it though
you had a good I did have great teachers
I had two theatre teachers miss Ratched
and mr. Barnard both of whom I feel like
sort of lit a match under my butt and
sort of helped me figure out what I
wanted to do with the rest of my life
and miss Ratched especially I feel like
she was sort of known as our like drill
sergeant but I feel like it trained me
to be a member of a professional theatre
group when's the last time you saw
people from your school like musical I
run into mine I'm still friends with
some of mine not a very long time we
haven't gone back in probably like two
yeah two years that's not too long
though no but I haven't I we didn't
we've never had a reunion event
well actually Kristen's High School
Musical teacher Miss Bishop in choir
class meet Katy are here come on out
y'all
[Applause]
[Applause]
totally she had no idea we did approve
it their people so we were like crazy
and you know what a big part of the show
is we always bring the somehow the drama
teacher was always so pivotal in these
kids lives no matter where they came
from and we always bring them back in
and it is like it's rich it's really
emotional because I think maybe for a
boy sometimes it might be a football
coach but it's the closest thing to
another parent that you have agreed okay
so like what's your favorite memory of
Kristen I always like like directing her
like because I know that's my favorite
memory but anyway my favorite memory
this is the truth that I have kept I
think I wrote it to you in this past
summer anyway that you know I when we
were doing lady be good and you were
doing like this on the couch with John
Murphy and who was like channeling John
Cleese and all of a sudden like you had
to get up and do some stuff and like you
just took the direction so perfectly and
I love when the light bulb goes on for
kids and you made that entire cast stop
and everybody was watching all the kids
you know we're just going oh and I think
that is just what they need to see a 15
year old pro so and to be captivating
like that it's inspiring oh my gosh she
stole the show
and I literally like put it back lady be
good yeah so that was it working what do
you remember working together we just
had a lot of fun yes so much fun we
shared a dressing room yeah because our
school is really small we do this dance
get like hyped up
[Laughter]
no she said no I remember being so
enamored with you though like even when
I first got when I got into high school
and then hearing about year because I
came from a different school district
hearing about your theatre program and
then being like oh my gosh I could
perform at Katy else I love that I grew
up with a lot of talented singers
everybody's always like oh you're such a
great skier I'm like you should see the
girls I grew up with like it was a very
like our class was it just had so much
talent like theater wise and singing
wise it's just a cool thing I think
that's why your show is gonna do so well
like honk words it's just really cool me
wanted to make this special because we
know that show is important to you so we
brought back a couple your face thank
you so much guys for taking the time
[Music]
family that went viral for a photo shoot
celebrating their youngest son's
adoption what struck a chord with a lot
of people was how multicultural the
family is here to tell us about it is
the Jones Baldwin family y'all give it
up
who is everyone here okay well this
gentleman beside me this is my husband
Rick then he's holding our two year old
son Princeton we just recently adopted
him and then we have Aiden you are in
with us for five years yeah he's eight
and then we have the teenagers on the
end they're 16 both of them yes Aria
she's my biological daughter from a
previous relationship all right
and then we have Carly and she's been
with us for a while we have their four
children are adopted and they recently
went viral for their photo shoot
celebrating the adoption of their
youngest two-year-old Princeton so we
mentioned that you didn't know Princeton
was white how did you find that out they
called me to do skin and skiing with him
which is like you know you go to the
hospital and you put him on your chest
and you bond with them you know and so
he was in the NICU and from people that
don't have babies that's a really
important thing for babies especially
babies that don't have moms around so
that's what they ask people where that
skin-to-skin is like really
developmental right yes stages yeah so I
get there and I'm excited and my
husband's like don't go to the hospital
cuz I know you're gonna bring the baby
home yeah and so I get there and I'm
like oh you know a lot of babies in
there and I'm like oh the black and
brown babies like which one am i but no
my chances she was like no that went
over there I was like baby you know not
just put them on my chance
[Laughter]
[Applause]
growling and I put them up here like I
fell in love with him and I was like my
husband was right I shouldn't came with
this I'm bringing them home keeping in
contact with all the biological parents
right yes opened I think that that's a
really cool yes it has to be you know I
think that it's really important to keep
them connected you know to their birth
families you know I call it vomit my
bunnies families I don't want to ever
put my children in a position to where
you know their question like well why
didn't you you know I know you know I
would rather them know and especially
they connected we have one of the
biological parents here today who wanted
to say thank you come on up John
[Applause]
all smiles in there's tea I'm so sorry
Noah my gosh what do you want to say to
this beautiful family
thank you Kia and your family for caring
for Princeton and just everything I
couldn't you know you know you're
welcome at this at that time I couldn't
I was 17 under straighten that wasn't
ready and I'm really really grateful for
you guys you amazing that is like you
are the greatest young man to know that
man this is more than I can handle right
now and you wanted to do something
better can do that and I think it's an
amazing thing that you get to see this
beautiful family that they're with like
what a beautiful family of mixed culture
and everybody's invited and it's just a
really nice thing is there anything you
want to tell John did you have y'all met
yet yes
oh yeah yep John was right there
Wheatley doing skiing skiing he was very
first parts and different things just
led to you know a separation but we got
in contact with each other a couple of
weeks ago when the adoption was
finalized because before then we
couldn't yeah and I told him I was like
it's time for you to meet your son yeah
and be acquainted with him because it
this is our son
[Applause]
[Music]
so did you ever actually get to meet him
after you did this who John Cena oh no
of course not not it's a whole yeah well
that's a bummer I mean I think he posted
did he post about it as well
and when he found out I don't know if he
posts for himself but his page he put he
put the picture of me on there he
doesn't say anything he doesn't caption
he doesn't tag me nothing he's because
you can't see him you got a guy I know I
love him a lot
alright well it's a first season he's
not here bring it over small budget but
I'm just thinking watching but wait see
he's watching and he's gonna love this
moment and I want you to perform this
song will you oh yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going